our next guest was known for his
indecisiveness during his playing days
baseball one day football the next the
only player to compete in the World
Series in Super Bowl despite his lack of
focus though he went on to
[Music]
known for his speed he allegedly ran a
42 40 at the NFL Scouting Combine in
borrowed shoes although no video exists
never at a loss for words he let his
play do the talking and then came back
and talked some more just to make sure
you
the uncensored
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
primetime show how much time you spend
on the outfit today
this is primetime though in I wanted to
be comfortable with a rubber bottom I
wanted to be in jeans I didn't want to
suit it up today now the last time when
we saw you in Minneapolis you took your
shoe off to show you
yeah the toes Beth so the toe was really
bad really bad ugly but it hurts now did
did you get it fixed
no no sigh what can you do what can you
do it now how did you hurt that I broke
on a slant I think it was Eric Metcalf
was running the slant and I stepped on
his heel and it just something like that
and that just I fail got up cool
and I was backpedaling in the next play
and I turned to run with him and just
failed it was I don't know what happened
went out of the game for a few plays and
they you know it up or OC so I wounded
duck so he's like let me try he's
wounded through a slant picked it hop to
like the two yard line when I hop
knocking out about the 2 yard line and
then how many years ago was that and
then how much longer did you play
numbers long after that that was bad
when did you know you were fast now we
raised the hood all the time that's what
we did that's what we did we raised
that's what we did that was the past
time to race we ran did you race for
money
ain't nobody had a money raised but
respect you know just respect me Jones
apartment we raised for respect last
time you launched a race ever
no one ever be here
don't think I've loved and tracked um
I'm sure but just not a like a hood race
is different that's different that's a
different thing biggest stakes there
yeah but they're guys like Joey Galloway
Darryl Greene a garage they were fast
yeah they could run runs real like and
Beau could run Boca flood and had power
if a wonderful boy it wouldn't be no
prayer I'm only sitting here because of
Oh Jackson I mean beau was mine but was
my goal like I needed both but when did
you know that you needed well or you
found buh-buh-buh but was the blueprint
you know we both did what we did but he
was that you everybody you know
everybody needs that arch nemesis and he
wasn't a nemesis but he was the goal
setter so you had something to try to
attain to and beau was that guy but he
did it differently beau was big guy pure
strength
you know physicality and you know I was
a everyday guy sighs I'm every day guys
sizing like and they couldn't relate to
a guy just doing it in a whole different
way and what beau did finish his
sentence if bo Jackson doesn't get
injured he will without a shadow of a
doubt go down as the greatest athlete
probably ever to death cuz I look at
Jackie Rob I think Jackie Robinson is
the greatest athlete of all time for a
variety of reasons okay
what he had to do just to get on the
field you know you start there he was
all-american he played basketball at
UCLA played football played baseball and
of course you know he's a running back
track and field in the end it's hard for
me to argue because we thought my Jackie
Robinson I can't debate none of that
I really can't but uh it's um at least
today that that got that hit and got it
I mean really has in I don't know if the
level of competition was as such oh
they're true
yeah yeah but I showed in opportunities
did everyone have opportunity yeah but
you also it's like when people go you
know could Bill Russell play now he
could but he wouldn't dominate yes
because he's built
LeBron's bigger than Bill Russell right
you know so you know could he play could
wilt play now they could play they just
wouldn't dumb will get buckets right now
yeah but but you know that's where
you're trying it's hard to compare it is
but can I compare Montana to Brady yes
yes Montana could play who would you
would you want is your quarterback those
are great okay and Brett Favre if I take
him off the board because Montana and
Brady are considered it would have to be
out of Montana Murray no that's good
Montana Marino abrading look Marino was
doing back in 1984 right like that was a
spreader unbelievable I played against
Marino with duper claiming that boy was
crazy and they were running deep rounds
that's why honestly that's one of the
main reasons I went to play two sports
on one day how could I leave a secondary
without me abandon the city against
Marino and I'm sitting on the bench for
nine innings in the cold I can I
justified it with my teammates it's no
way in the world you could justify what
role did Nike play none I already had an
ideal I know but I didn't know if Nike
encouraged you know why would they that
was already proud I'm just asking the
questions here okay make me no more than
Brad
but they provided the plane but provided
the jet but it was gonna happen anyway
it's just like just rekindling this
whole story
I never even know how to helicopter
showed up to practice every day who who
did that I didn't pay for it I don't
happen I think I was just talking in the
media when there's like you know 85
anybody from Atlanta you know 85 is
packed especially in those hours yeah
and I had to go from football practice
to the baseball game you know why wasn't
it why wasn't it celebrated more because
if somebody had a microphone in front of
their mouth we didn't have social media
we can tell a side of the story
someone it was was wrong they missed it
they were wrong they did not know that
my contract was over in baseball in July
so how am I the villain I'm not a bad
guy when I'm helping a whole nother
organization how did you make me to be
the bad guy how did they this right here
the microphone yes and how can we
regurgitate something that someone told
you you'd even check your facts
but it's that part of the reason why you
wanted this 3430 or you're glad you can
actually tell that tell the story it's
like you know bow when bow got is thirty
four thirty a whole new generation
realized yeah what Bo Jackson and who Bo
Jackson was well they kept asking here
at the year every year in probably
pretty much for the football one I see
now I see if we're gonna do it let's do
it let's do this let's let the people
know what really happened behind the
curtains on the to sport in one day
let's do it that way and that's what we
did anything surprise you when he
watched no it did anything bother you
yeah yeah what bothered you
first of all I don't know if you're
being honest and truthful why you've
refrained to come on camera that's
number one that's the red flag number
two wait who didn't come on camera by
because Tim McCarver okay they didn't
want to play a role in it
I understand it's cool but did you get
along with Bobby Cox Bobby Cox is my god
yeah Bobby okay no but I was a good man
yeah bill is yeah it's good man I
understand Cheryl's not coming on I do
understand that but why I mean just tell
it and then Tim McCarver didn't want to
come on Tim McCarver well you probably
figured why he wasn't gonna come on
let's just do it how did that come about
though that that McCarver like you had
that I don't know if it's anger not
winning but but you dumped ice water on
him let me let me tell you what I'm
gonna be perfect I mean my momma called
me and she said baby talk about you like
dog who is this guy keep talking about
you to hold dirt game what is wrong well
I'm from when you mix mighty mama man
okay I didn't know about mom and I
handled it and I wouldn't I've never
tasted alcohol I've never been drunk I
never had a drink in my life I've never
been drunk so I'm not a champagne
pouring guy I don't believe in it I
don't even believe touching alcohol so
I'm not a champagne pouring guy after a
victory
water so it would've had been more
appropriate if it would have been
champagne because it was gonna be
something yeah it was going to be
something because I had to cool him off
a little bit because he he he was just
speaking out of turn I still to this day
don't understand how can you make me out
to be the bad guy and I don't even have
a contract and then in that piece john
shareholds allege that my attorney had a
handshake deal with him that i would
play two sports I would play baseball
exclusively you know playoffs everybody
makes the same amount of money so what
deal did you consummate what deal could
have been it was never deal the 34 30s
Deion's double play it's on the
mothership and premiered last night yeah
but they'll be showing that also do it
is tonight premiers tonight oh I got to
see it because somebody with you your
group senator me okay yeah so I got to
download that you're important well I
appreciate that you're big to do my
homework here you can see Dion
throughout the week NFL Network Super
Bowl coverage from Atlanta if in you
know I want you understand this your
prime time I'm daytime I'm just letting
you know I like that I I don't know if
you know I'm gonna have an outfit or
anything I don't have to stay up late
like of your daytime I don't have to
stay up late I like that yeah and like
around 7:00 to 7:30 you go with the
shorties does anybody say shorties
anymore
shouting Oh shouting shouting show date
time doesn't talk like that
if Kyler Murray walked in said hey prime
help me he's gonna do it okay so you're
gonna sit down with him yes sir and we
will you give them advice I'm not gonna
give them advice if you don't want
anybody's I'm gonna ask it we keep
forgetting the kid as a heart you you go
with your heart is man everybody keep
telling this kid do it you need to do
this you need to do this
where's his heart I need to locate his
heart when I find out where his heart is
then I could give him some advice and
wisdom that was the point I made through
all of this is
what do you love this because you may
you may get make more money now can you
love two things equally no one is neat
and one is long and profound one is
needing one as won't often tans we want
what we need but one's gonna suffer
something's gonna stuff I think he loves
football I do too and I think he's good
at baseball got a contract with baseball
but if you said what do you love I do
too
I think he'd say but this is the problem
this kid hadn't been criticized yet what
I mean yet is you know it's coming
yes it comes no one has really said oh
you know how's this gonna happen
disciplinary problems what happened with
that so all that's coming and I prayed
that he can handle that man because he
hadn't been shot at their you know
college kids we we love all them but now
when it's time for the draft we start
chanting my part and that's not right
it's not fair to the kid but now you
because you can ready to make grown man
money so now they got to start treating
you like a grumpy
well it it gonna take shots it and we
give you about a year before we get
tired of you like we're tired of the
story there you go and and look if
you're a basketball player like Zion
Williamson is going to escape it because
he's gonna go to the NBA
he came back for a second year then we
start to nitpick there a little bit that
is true right that's how it works oh
you're also I mentioned the D on prime
time tonight on the mothership at 9:00
Eastern NFL Network coverage and mint
mobile yes
what do you don't mean all within the
confines of marriage you know when a
brother say you got a lot of kids all
within the confines of marriage myself
so I have a plethora of phone bills so I
partnered with met mobile I mean we're
gonna challenge the status quo man we we
tie to these big-time companies it's
charging crazy you know what I mean all
these phone bills coming in so I could
consolidate man $20 package I love it be
nice if day time got into this with
prime time that'd be nice thank you for
the grill hey let me tell you something
man that company is unbelievable Trager
Trager hooks me up man now has Chad ever
been to your house my pit master no
where where's Chad okay so right there
yeah it looks like a pit master Chad
Chad is the prime time I mean like if
you said pit master and I had to pick
him out of line up out of it okay I can
send that that dude to your house to
grill for you in Texas
okay you know what we may do that on the
fourth you you you booked up on the
fourth when he comes down yeah invite
all the friends and um country - Chad
I've caught you forever I live in the
country I love it you like to fish a
little bit yes sir I guess you know you
want him he came in for my Christmas
party yeah cooked up two pigs on the
tray Kirk ain't dude it did the whole
thing was anybody country and get rid of
it it's a mint mobile MOBAs awesome
Deon's double play that's tonight at
9:00 on leave tonight at 9:00 on the
mothership and also and I try to get him
to have 21 because it was more
appropriate which 20 they still wanted
you to say so NFL Network Super Bowl
coverage from Atlanta it's always great
to see you
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]